To say that someone has ‘daddy issues’
is a somewhat rude and humiliating way of
alluding to a very understandable longing:
for a father who is strong and wise, who is
judicious, kind, perhaps at points tough,
but always fair – and ultimately, always
on our side. It would be so understandable
if we were to feel we wanted someone like
this in our lives, especially at moments of
confusion and chaos. The longing for a strong
father has been a recurring theme in history.
Most religions have conceived of their central
divinities as male parents. In ancient Greece,
Zeus was described as the ‘father of men
and Gods’; in Christianity, God was the
heavenly father; in Germanic mythology, Odin
was the Allfather, the father of all other
gods. The longing has been no less present
in secular culture. In the US, the individuals
who led the war of independence and drew up
the constitution came to be known as the Founding
Fathers; Garibaldi, the dignified and authoritative
man who fought for the unification of Italy
in the 19th century, earned himself the title
of the ‘father of the fatherland’. In
early childhood, we are all immensely weak
and in need of protection. We can’t understand
the world, we are so fragile, we could be
killed by a moderately sized dog; so much
feels mysterious and outside of our control.
A hunger for a ‘daddy’ is – in the circumstances
– wholly natural. A grown man inevitably
and rightly seems immensely impressive to
a small child. They appear to know everything:
the capital of New Zealand, how to drive a
car, how to say a few words in a foreign language,
how to peel an avocado. They go to bed mysteriously
late. They’re up before you. In the swimming
pool, you can put your arms around their neck
and rest on their back; they once kicked a
football so high, you nearly couldn’t see
it; they take you on their shoulders and help
you touch the ceiling. It’s beyond astonishing
– when one is four.. The paradox of daddy
issues is that those who have them are – almost
always – people who didn’t have very good
fathers when they were small. Perhaps one’s
father was strong but ultimately cruel, bullying
or disinterested. Perhaps he was more interested
in another sibling or in his work. Perhaps
he wasn’t around much, left the house after
a divorce or died young. The adult longing
for a father is not the result of having had
a good father in childhood: it’s a consequence
of abandonment. The longing can incline to
us some tricky patterns of behaviour. However
mature and sceptical we may be in most areas,
in relation to the idea of male protection,
we remain a little like the young child we
once were and haven’t been allowed to mature
away from. We secretly yearn for a man to
step in and fulfill an unquenched fantasy
role. They’ll take charge; they’ll make
the big decisions, they’ll be tough and
certain and make our problems go away. They’ll
make sure the money side of things is sorted,
they’ll get angry and aggressive with anyone
who hurts us; they will be proud of us and
love us as we are. We’ll be looking out
for daddies in friendships, at work and, not
least, in politics. The danger is that these
‘daddies’ may in the end hugely damage
our trust, for it isn’t in anyone’s power
to assuage the sort of longings we bring to
bear on them. They may know very well what
we want, and naively or cynically promise
to provide it for us, but gradually – too
late – we stand to realise that they had
a thousand flaws, as we all do. We may realise
that they are bullying rather than noble;
that our enemies haven’t gone away; that
they couldn’t help us; that there isn’t
in fact enough money in the world to do what
they promised; and that – in fact – they
didn’t really love us at all. The fantasy
‘Daddy’ figure of adulthood isn’t in
fact a good father for one big reason: truly
good humans know they aren’t that powerful
and are happy to admit to the fact cleanly
and honestly, just as soon as we are ready
to take the news, which is normally when we
are around twelve years old and conscious
of new powers and capacities. A good father
doesn’t – beyond that age – pretend
to be all powerful, they confess they can’t
solve all our problems and can’t magically
save us from a myriad of dangers, no matter
how much they wish they could. The good daddy
disappoints us just as soon as we are strong
enough to bear reality. Out of love they deflate
the idea that there could ever be a perfect,
ideal daddy. They try as best they can to
help us grow up. If we encounter someone who
has daddy issues, the temptation is to get
frustrated, tell them to mature, mock them
and – in particular – poke fun at the
particular daddy figure they might have identified.
This isn’t either a very wise or ultimately
a very kind strategy. It simply tends to entrench
their devotion – because, whenever we are
attacked, we of course feel ever more intensely
than ever the need for the protection of an
idealised father. What we really need to help
us out of our daddy issues is something more
like the actions of a genuinely good father:
someone who truly acknowledges our suffering
and our fears, who deeply wants what is best
for us and isn’t reluctant to say so; but
who, at the same time – out of love – wants
to help us come to terms with a messy and
essentially disappointing world; a man who
– out of love – will encourage us to be
independent and, specifically, not to fantasise
that anyone, however outwardly imposing, can
ever do the impossible. Good daddies allow
us to bear the truth that there are, in the
end, no ‘daddies’. .
We love bringing you these films.  If you want to help us to keep bring you thoughtful content
please consider supporting us by visiting our shop at the link on your screen now.